foreign
cyber security is a hot button topic
it's also filled with a massive demand
for professionals cyber security has
emerged as a critical field in today's
technology driven world as digital
Reliance grows for businesses and
governments the demand for cyber
Security Experts has skyrocketed for
those considering a cyber security
degree finding the best university is
crucial for a comprehensive education
and a successful career in this video we
will explore the world's top university
for cyber security
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
MIT located in Cambridge Massachusetts
stands out as the best university for
cyber security globally its computer
science and artificial intelligence
laboratory csail is a renowned Research
Center with a strong focus on cyber
security
mit's program Embraces
interdisciplinarity involving faculty
from computer science electrical
engineering public policy and more MIT
cyber security program boast exceptional
faculty and offer students SS to
cutting-edge research facilities and
Technology the cyber security and
internet policy research initiative
cipri a research center within MIT
addresses cyber security policy issues
Additionally the MIT Lincoln laboratory
a federally funded research and
development center provides hands-on
experience in technique real-world cyber
security challenges other top
universities for cyber security include
Stanford University in California
Carnage Milan University in Penny
Slovenia and the University of Cambridge
each of these institutions offer a
comprehensive cyber security curriculum
outstanding faculty and access to the
state-of-the-art research facilities as
the importance of cyber security
continues to grow these universities
provide invaluable opportunities to
shape the future of cyber security and
make a significant impact in their
digital landscape but where do you start
if you are considering a career in this
exciting and ever-evolving Industry
right here in this video we'll introduce
you to the best universities for cyber
security in the USA United States of
America let's Jump Right In Here are the
five universities known for their
exceptional University programs and the
number one on the list is Carnage Mellon
University that is located in Pittsburgh
penis Slovenia CMU is renowned for its
excellence in cyber security education
the information networking Institute the
information networking Institute inih
CMU offers top-notch programs in
information security and cyber security
including Masters and PhD degrees the
programs cover a wide range of cyber
security topics from cryptography and
network security to digital forensics
and incident response CMU strength lies
in its strong focus on practical
application and Hands-On learning the
university is home to the CRT division a
world leading cyber security Research
Center that plays a crucial role in
advancing the field and number two on
the list is Massachusetts Institute of
Technology mid that is based in
Cambridge Massachusetts it's a world
renowned institution known for Cutting
Edge research and Innovation its
comprehensive cyber security program is
offered through the computer science and
artificial intelligence laboratory csail
a Premier Research Center in the AI and
cyber security domains students at MIT
gain a solid foundation in cyber
security Concepts while also benefiting
from the intersection of technology and
management through the Sloan School of
Management specialized program in
information technology and management
this multi-disciplinary approach
prepares graduates to excel in various
aspects of cyber security from technical
implementation to strategic decision
making and here simply learn brings you
the course in collaboration with MIT
that presents an incredible opportunity
to upskill in the field of cyber
security our postgraduate program in
cyber security is designed to equip you
with the expertise needed to thrive in
this rapidly growing industry through
this partnership with MIT schwarzmann
College of computing you will gain
access to world-class resources in
top-notch faculty ensuring a
cutting-edge learning experience and why
should you choose this program so the
number one reason is MIT thought leaders
you will attend live master classes
delivered by distinguished MIT faculty
learning from the best Minds in the
field the next is easy Council benefits
you will gain exclusive access to
learning kits exam vouchers and modules
from EC Council a leading Authority in
cyber security education then MIT csil
Community you will become the part of
the MIT csail professional programs
community and engage with like-minded PS
and experts then we have industry case
studies you will gain practical insights
from 4 real world industry case studies
led by MIT professors don't miss this
opportunity to upskill with the best and
only in a postgraduate program in cyber
security and Propel your career to new
heights with simply learn nmit's combine
expertise secure your future in the
dynamic world of cyber security today
and now number three on the list is
Stanford University that is located in
Silicon Valley and is at the heart of
technology and Innovation Stanford cyber
security programs are part of its
computer science department offering
Masters and PhD degrees with a
specialization in cyber security
Stanford's focus on research and
Innovation is evident through its
pioneering work in areas like
cryptography and secure systems
Additionally the center for
International Security and cooperation
CI SAC at Stanford conducts valuable
research on cyber security policy
Bridging the Gap between technology and
policy considerations and the number
four on the list is Georgia Institute of
Technology Georgia Tech that is situated
in Atlanta Georgia that boasts a robust
cyber security program with a variety of
degree options students can pursue
Masters and PhD degrees in cyber
security or a specialized Masters in
cyber security and privacy Georgia tax
Institute of information security and
privacy iisp is actively engaged in
Cutting Edge research across various
cyber security domains the University's
strong emphasis on research and
collaboration with industry Partners
creates ample opportunities for students
to engage in real world projects and now
number five on the list is University of
California Berkeley UC Berkeley that is
located in San Francisco Bay Area offers
a range of cyber Security Programs
through its computer science department
students can pursue Masters and PhD
degrees with a focus on cyber security
gaining a comprehensive understanding of
various cyber security challenges UC
Berkeley Center for long-term cyber
security cltc conducts research on the
societal impact of cyber security
emphasizing the broader implications of
technological advancements in the field
and these universities stand out for the
commitment to Excellence in cyber
security Education and Research each
institution offers unique strengths and
opportunities ensuring that students
receive a well-rounded education and
preparation for successful careers in
the dynamic and our evolving field of
cyber security these universities have
consistently demonstrated excellence in
cyber security Education and Research
making them attractive choices for
students aspiring to build a successful
career in this Dynamic field so there
you have it the top five universities
for cyber security in the USA these
schools provide an excellent start for
anyone looking to make a splash in the
cyber security field and this was all
for this tutorial hope you guys found it
informative and helpful now let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers by opting for the
simplyness postgraduate program that is
in collaboration with MIT Schwartzman
College of computing hi I'm Philip I'm
61 years old and last year IOP skill
with simply learned postgraduate program
at cyber security after working 30 years
in the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors I worked with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
after I took the course but first and
foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first
and if you like this session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here